[موسيقى]
قاعدة بحثية
لتربية الباندا العملاقة في
الواقع سأكون أكثر سعادة إذا اتصل بي أحد الأشخاص ببانداني
[موسيقى]
قبل عشر سنوات عندما أتيت للعمل
في
قاعدة البحث لأول مرة أشعر أن كل شيء
بدا جديدًا بالنسبة
لي لاحقًا وجدت أنه على الرغم من  بدا الأمر
بسيطًا ،
كان هناك الكثير لنتعلمه
بشكل عام ، لا يمكن للباندا العملاقة تربية
طفل واحد إلا
إذا أنجبت الأم طفلًا واحدًا ،
فسنسمح لها بتربية الطفل
بمفردها ،
فنحن نقدم لها بعض المساعدة فقط ،
ولكن إذا ولدت الأم طفلين
الأطفال ،
ثم لدينا الكثير لنفعله هنا ،
نذهب لنجلس هنا
، فلنجلس هنا ، المهمة الأولى في
اليوم
هي مساعدة صغار الباندا على التبرز
مثل هذا الباندا البالغ من العمر نصف عام والذي يمكنه أن
يتغوط في رئته
ستساعده والدته عن طريق  لعق
المربيات طرقنا الخاصة ولكن يجب علينا
تسجيل
كل إجراء لأنه أمر مهم
بالنسبة لمرضى البحث ،
وسوف أساعدك
الآن وأتذكر عندما ساعدت لأول مرة في لعبة ping poo ،
استخدمت الكثير من الشرائط عليه لم
يعجبه  بالطريقة التي ساعدته بها
ولم أتوقف أبدًا عن النضال والصراخ ،
كنت خائفًا جدًا من إيذائه بعد ذلك عدة
مرات
عندما أصبحت من ذوي الخبرة ، تمكنت الأبقار
أخيرًا من أخذ البراز
بسهولة وشعورًا جيدًا بالأمل في أن تتمكن من تناول
المزيد عندما تعود إلى والدتك ،
فأنت تنمو بسرعة لدرجة
أنني بالكاد أستطيع  احمل
[موسيقى]
انظر إلى أن والدتك تقف هناك
لأنك تفتقدك كثيرًا لدرجة أن
أكواب القلم الرصاص تتوقف عن شرب الحليب حتى
يبلغوا عامًا تقريبًا
بالنسبة لهؤلاء الأطفال المدربين ، حيث يمكنهم فقط
شرب حليب أمهاتهم
واحدًا تلو
الآخر عندما يكون لدى دب باندا  لحظة رائعة
مع والدته ،
أفضل لفة انتظار أخرى ،
لا تقلق من أنه سيكون لديك قريبًا ،
فمن الصعب على حيوانات الباندا في هذا
العمر حمل الزجاجة
التي نحتاجها لمساعدتهم حتى بعد 5 أشهر
يمكنهم شرب الحليب بمفردهم
تمامًا مثل الإنسان  الأطفال
لا يتحركون ، دعونا نظف فمك وأسنانك
تجلس بشكل مستقيم وتأخذ زوبعة قد
تشعر بتحسن
من الضروري أن تزنهم إذا كنت
تريد مراقبة
مقدار ما يأكلونه وكم الوزن
الذي يحصلون
عليه
هذا الباندا شقي جدًا لدرجة
أنه لم يستطع التوقف عن نشر
الأشياء  حان وقت اللعب ،
دعنا نركب هذا الحصان الصغير بالقدم
اليسرى والقدم اليسرى يديك
تقضي يومًا مثيرًا ، تمامًا مثل جميع عجول الباندا الصغيرة التي تعيش في
الحيوانات ، والتي
تتوق دائمًا
للعب هذا الحقل العشبي ،
حتى أن قطعة واحدة من الأوراق
يمكن أن تجذب انتباههم
كل طفل يحتاج إلى  تعلم كيفية المشي وتبدأ
أكواب الباندا
عندما يبلغون من العمر ثلاثة أو أربعة أشهر
بالنظر من خلف الشرطي يعمل
مع زره يتأرجح من جانب إلى آخر
وسوف يتعثر على الأرض بالفرن
اللطيف حقًا
في حوالي نصف عام يمكن للباندا المشي
بسلاسة
بالإضافة إلى تسلق الأشجار ، نحن نرعى
الكؤوس
منذ يوم ولادتهم
ونشاهدهم يكبرون
ويأكلون الخيزران ويلعبون مع الأصدقاء
، يبدو الأمر وكأننا أنجزنا
شيئًا
مثل أم تراقب أطفالها
التخرج ،
سأستمر في مجالسة فروة الرأس هذه
حتى يبلغوا من
العمر عامين بمجرد حصولهم على أجنحة ،
وسيتولى زملائي المسؤولية ، وسيكون من
الصعب جدًا بالنسبة لي أن أقول وداعًا
لكوني مربية باندا لمدة 10 سنوات ، لقد
رأيت الكثير من الأبقار تكبر.
أحب البقاء معهم ، فنحن
كعائلة
نعيش معًا
[موسيقى] ،
لذا
تجلب الباندا الكثير من الأفراح
والسعادة للناس من جميع أنحاء العالم ،
فنحن هنا في انتظارك لتأتي إلى
سوترا وتستمتع بالمناظر
الطبيعية الجميلة والباندا الجميلة
[موسيقى]
أنت